-You also auditioned
for the Aflac Duck.
-Yes, I did.
-Wow.
-Yeah, I just found out like -
I'm not making this up.
Like two years ago,
my agent was like, "You know
that was between you and Gilbert
Gottfried."
-Really?
-And I'm like, "What?!
Why are you telling me this now?
This was like 20 years ago."
And it was, like,
I went into this audition.
You know, the Aflac Duck, right?
-Yeah, yeah.
-And so I go in.
She's like,
"You have this audition
for this voiceover for Aflac."
"Okay, great."
So, I go to the audition.
I go in this booth.
You know, like, the sound booth.
They're behind the glass,
and you have your headphones on.
And the music stand
with the script.
And they're like, "Go ahea
and read the script."
And I'm like...
"yeah, it's right next to you.
And I'm like, "Okay. Aflac."
[ Laughter ]
I don't understand.
Nobody told me
I was supposed to be a duck.
Nobody gave me any direction
-No?
-No, nothing.
-Oh, my God!
-And they're all,
like, behind the glass.
You can't hear them. Like...
[ Laughter ]
"Can you try it again?
Can you try it again?"
I'm like, "Aflac.
I don't -- I don't understand.
And they're like,
"Thank you so much."
-Oh, my God.
-I didn't get it.
-That's crazy.
I mean, that's very...
That's very unfair,
because Gilbert, of course
has, like, almost
a natural duck voice.
[ Laughter ]
So it was very unfair
to not give you that direction
-Listen to this bull[Bleep
-Yeah.
-You -- This is amazing.
Your last season
of "Will & Grace."
-This is the last season
It was supposed to be
10 episodes.
This guy walking around
with a camera,
just right in front of us?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Okay, um...
[ Laughter ]
So, I mean, hi.
I mean, it's so weird.
-Yeah, yeah.
He's a crime-scene photographer.
[ Laughter ]
He works for the NYPD.
So, yeah, yeah.
-Well, that's -- That's --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, that's great.
We've definitely murdered
this segment.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-So, no.
-We'd love you to stick around
for the chalk outline,
if you don't mind.
[ Laughter ]
-Just on the floor?
No, we were going to do
10 episodes for
this "Will & Grace" reboot
and it ended up being 52.
So blessed.
-That's so amazing.
-So grateful.
So honored that the fans
wanted us to do it.
So it's been
such a dream come true
to get everybody together again,
and here we are.
You know, it's --
We have four more to tape.
And then we're done.
And the season's airing
as we speak.
-And you wrote and starred i
a movie?
-Did you direct it?
-So "lazy Susan."
-Okay.
-It's with Allison Janney,
Margo Martindale, Matthew
Broderick, Jim Rash.
A great cast.
I wrote it, I starred in it.
It comes out in April next year.
-That's fantastic.
And then I have another thing,
called "Q-Force,"
which is on Netflix
for 10 episodes.
An animated series.
Gay James Bond.
-Oh, yeah, gay James Bond.
I read about this.
It's very exciting.
-So you know Mike Schur.
-Yes, of course.
-Mike Schur who you used t
work with on "SNL."
And he created "Parks and Rec.
And so I'm driving to work
and his office is
on the same lot
"Will & Grace" is.
So I'm driving, I see him,
and I roll down my window.
I go, "Mike, you want to..."
And he's the, like, the nicest
greatest guy ever.
-Yes, he is.
-I go, "Do you want to do
a show together?"
And he goes, "I don't know
What is it?"
I go, "Gay James Bond."
And he goes,
"Yes, I'm doing that show.
-Right.
-"Of course
I'm doing that show."
-That's fantastic.
-So, yeah.
And then the other thing
that I'm working on, too,
is this amazing thing
called Cubcoats.
Cubcoats is this --
It's awesome.
It's a two-in-one product
for kids.
It's a stuffed animal
that you unzip,
and it turns into a hoodie
-Fantastic.
-And why I love it
and I love the company
is because Cubcoats strives to
make children's lives better
And because of that,
we're giving away 1,000 Cubcoats
to the Children's Hospital
of Los Angeles.
And for every Cubcoat purchase
at cubcoats.com,
some of the proceeds go
to the Children's Hospital
of Los Angeles, as well.
-That's fantastic.
You brought me
a couple Cubcoats.
-I did, yeah, yeah.
-Can't wait
to get the kids in them.
Thank you so much
for being in town.
It's great to see you.
Sean Hayes, everybody.